I know that I'll be on is called
educating innovative societies and it
really ties in tightly to one of my main
research goals creation of an equitable
education around the world for societies
that will be prepared to create two
innovations of the 21st century that are
going to solve some of the world's
greatest problems one of the major
issues is that the population in the
global South is exploding and very soon
the majority of the world's learners
from birth through 18 are going to be
located in Africa fortunately many many
more children are able to access
schooling than ever before but it also
means that we have a lack of teachers a
lack of facilities and a lack of quality
educational opportunities and so one of
my goals and one of the goals of this
panel is to understand how we might
support these learners in having all of
the opportunities that children from
other places of the world have and that
we understand how we can do that in a
way that produces a society that has
just outcomes and and not only that but
that they also are able to rise above to
reach their full potential when they
come of age and they graduate from the
school system
I find this research so interesting
because I love going and learning from
other people around the world so one of
my favorite things to do is sit in
classrooms in a country where I have
never been before
and just soak it in understand how
teachers are teaching how kids interact
with one another how people learn and
I'm constantly learning something new
that I can use as I think about how do
we create technologies that can enhance
the the situation and and make education
even better